[Music]
in this video we will talk about the
neuromuscular Junction the neuromuscular
Junction is a connection between the
motor neuron and a muscle fiber through
which the motor neuron activates the
muscle let's first draw a brief diagram
of the neuromuscular Junction to
understand its structure so as you can
see this is the axon of the motor neuron
this is the axon terminal this is the
presynaptic membrane and these are the
various vesicles which contain the
acetylcholine that is a neurotransmitter
involved in the action this is the
voltage-gated calcium channels and this
is the synaptic cleft which is
approximately 30 nanometers in size this
is the postsynaptic membrane also known
as sarcolemma these three structures
together form the synapse
now these ion channels you see on the
postsynaptic clefts these are the
acetylcholine receptors which are
basically the voltage-gated sodium
channels this was a brief description
about the structure let's see how the
neuromuscular Junction acts it all
starts when the action potential reaches
the axon terminal now this action
potential first acts upon the calcium
channels since these are voltage-gated
these open up and they cause the influx
of the calcium into the axon terminal
after this influx the calcium basically
activates a group of proteins known as
the snare proteins which involve
proteins like synaptic brevin and
syntaxin and these proteins when
activated they attach to the membrane of
the synaptic vesicles and cause the
exocytosis of these vesicles the they
fuse with the presynaptic membrane and
they cause the
of the acetylcholine into the synaptic
cleft the next step in the transmission
is the action of the acetylcholine on
the acetylcholine receptors since these
are sodium channels these open up and
cause an influx of sodium ions into the
muscle fiber since sodium is a positive
ion it causes the generation of action
potential in the muscle fiber which in
turn leads to either muscular
contraction or it may also lead to the
increase in the tone of the muscle so
after the acetylcholine has acted on the
muscle the enzyme acetylcholinesterase
which is also present in the synaptic
cleft
it acts upon the excess of the
acetylcholine and it degrades their
style choline so that no more further
than action of the acetylcholine on the
acetylcholine receptors take place this
was a brief description about the
structure and action of the
neuromuscular Junction I hope you find
this video informative don't forget to
hit the like button and also make sure
to subscribe to our channel for regular
medical videos thank you so much guys
for watching this video